so last year a fascinating study came
out in the journal Science from a team
led by Betsy Sparrow at Columbia and in
this study the scientists showed that
people who used Google and who thought
that they would be able to access
information on a computer later on
didn't remember it as well as the people
who didn't think they would have access
to it so you have one kind of key
variable do you think you'll be able to
use your computer later on to find this
information the answer is no you're
going to remember it if the answer is
yes you're not going to remember it but
you will remember where to find it so
you'll remember where it was stored
you'll remember what the folder was
you'll remember how to access it on the
computer so it's not that you're not
remembering anything it's that you're
remembering a very different thing do
you use your memory to store the actual
piece of information do you use it to
store the retrieval process so I take a
few things from this thing one
technology can be very bad for our
memory if we let it be bad for it so if
we always rely on it and if we have this
attitude of oh I don't need to remember
this because I'll always be able to look
it up you won't remember it and then you
won't have that knowledge in your head
and then you won't have anything in your
attic to play with you won't have that
knowledge base you won't be able to be
imaginative like Holmes you won't be
able to reach those conclusions because
your attic will be pretty bare but we
can also use it to enhance her memory by
saying okay I know that there are these
great technological benefits why don't I
use that to create this virtual storage
space for myself so Holmes does this to
Holmes has files that he accesses and he
says Watson you know look up my file for
this case look up my file for this case
so he remembers that he has the file he
remembers that there was a case he
doesn't necessarily remember all of
these details so you can think of Google
as this vastly expanded Holmes the in
filing system so you can use it for
exactly that what are the things that I
want to remember and that I want to be
able to access later
on and focus on remembering how to
access them and then keep your mind
space for those things that you think
will be important for you to know at any
point so the exercise that I like to say
for myself is if I were on a desert
island with no power or I don't even
have to go to a desert island in
hurricane sandy I had no power no
internet no cell phone service nothing
so if hurricane sandy strikes again and
I don't have anything do I have
everything that I need immediately in my
head what are those things that I really
can't rely on a computer for